what we're going to do here is a little
bit of a case study in doing taxes so we
have a situation where someone is
bringing in fifty thousand dollars in
this current tax year and gross income
so this is everything from their
salaries tips they might make if they
act as a contractor payments for that it
could be dividend income if they own
stocks it could be interest on on bank
accounts or CDs that they might have and
so when you add up all of that we get to
fifty thousand dollars now you aren't
taxed on your gross income just as is
typically you're going to adjust it to
figure out what your taxable income is
and then you will go and look at the
various tax brackets and calculate your
taxes and just so you know these are not
the real tax brackets in the United
States these have never been the real
tax brackets in the United States I
simplified it one to make the numbers
easy so I can do it with back of the
envelope math but also these are
constantly changing in the real world
and I don't want to have to keep redoing
this video every time they change the
tax brackets but it's going to give you
the general idea of what's going on so
these are made up tax brackets and tax
rates and this is also a made-up
standard deduction we're going to talk
in a little bit about what a standard
deduction is
so going back to the case study of this
person in this taxable year gross income
fifty thousand dollars and then they
have what we're calling above the line
deductions and above the line deductions
you can view these as deductions to your
gross income that you can make no matter
what so and it the history of why it's
called above the line it's the first
form of the typical tax form so let me
say above the line
above the line you can make these types
of deductions no matter what this isn't
an exhaustive list but these are ones
that are actually reasonably typical
things like a 401k contribution this is
a pre-tax contribution to a retirement
account to A A Defined contribution
retirement account so so to speak where
you put a certain amount of money every
year and that money is pre-taxed so it
gets taken down from your gross income
to figure out what your actual taxable
income is going to be student loan
interest is also typically deductible
from your gross income and when we
deduct those we are left with our
adjusted gross income let me write here
add adjusted
I lost a t there adjusted gross
income which in this case is going to be
what's going to be fifty thousand
dollars minus two thousand minus three
thousand so that gets us to forty five
thousand dollars
now we're not ready to just take this
forty five thousand dollars and figure
out how that would be taxed based on
this schedule here this chart right over
here we're not ready to make more
deductions and we can view these as
below the line deductions and this is
where it gets interesting you could go
the path of itemized deductions so
that's looking at things like okay did
you make any donations to charity or do
you have any uh mortgage interest on
your home mortgage and so let me write
these These are itemized
itemized so if you itemized your
deductions you'd say okay I have a total
of nine thousand dollars of itemized
deductions right over here I would take
that from the forty five thousand
dollars and I could have a situation
where my taxable
taxable income
it would be forty five thousand minus
nine which is going to be let me draw a
little line over here this is going to
be thirty six thousand dollars of
taxable income
now you could just take that and figure
out what you're now going to have to pay
but there's another interesting
alternative path that you should know
about as opposed to itemizing your
deductions you're below the line
deductions so to speak where you have to
list them all out your other option is
to just take the standard deduction
now in this situation the standard
deduction is ten thousand dollars so
let's see what happens if instead of
itemizing our deductions we were to just
take out the ten thousand dollar
standard deduction well in that
situation our taxable income is going to
be forty five thousand minus 10 000
which is going to be thirty five
thousand dollars now generally speaking
unless you just like giving money to the
government you want to minimize your
taxable income you want to do that
legally and in this situation when we
pick the standard deduction route we
actually have a lower taxable income so
this is the path that you're going to
want to take and now that we've
calculated this taxable income this
thirty five thousand dollars we are
ready to now actually calculate based on
the schedule of the actual tax brackets
so one way to think about it is the
first 10 000 right over here we are
going to have no tax so let me put that
here so we have 10K
no tax no tax now the next ten thousand
dollars right over here is going to be
taxed at ten percent so the next 10K
is going to be taxed at 10 percent so
now sorry my dog barked so so now we've
accounted for 20K we have fifteen
thousand dollars left so we go into the
next bracket the next bracket actually
accounts for the next twenty thousand we
don't have that much but if I just right
over here say okay my next 15K which is
all I have Falls over here so I'm going
to say the next 15K
is going to be taxed at 20 percent and
this is federal taxes that we are
talking about here you're gonna have to
do it another time for your state taxes
but now let's calculate our total tax
first ten thousand dollars no tax so
we'd have to worry about that now ten
thousand dollars being taxed at ten
percent ten percent of ten thousand is
one thousand dollars and then fifteen
thousand dollars being taxed at twenty
percent that's going to be three
thousand dollars and so you add these up
and you get a total federal tax in this
situation and this made up tax brackets
that I just did in this made up example
of four thousand dollars but hopefully
that gives you an idea of how taxes are
actually calculated and a little bit of
the terminology